in brussels europe's leaders are
gathering just as brexit talks hit a
critical moment
officially they'll just get a briefing
on the state of negotiations
but the reality is that brexit is on
everyone's mind
i prefer no deal that a bad deal we have
to have a deal where we are all able to
to have the guarantees that we find in
proper way to get out of this situation
divorces are never easy today we got
these
eu documents outlining ideas for how to
handle no deal brexit
emergency measures on transport and
freight that europe insists
will keep things moving but they say it
can't be as comfortable and easy as
recent decades
among the suggestions the idea of
another year of shared access to british
waters
a plan quickly dismissed as unacceptable
by british government sources
but the pressure to plan for no deal is
growing on both sides of the channel
whether it will be um chaos on day one
will depend on how collectively we rise
to the challenge
um how well coordinated we are um
and uh i am sure that there will be
hiccups
uh it would be naive to think that
everything would be ready on day one and
perfectly operational today talks
continued between british and
eu negotiators to try to find some kind
of compromise
you can just see lord frost through the
window he'd avoided the waiting cameras
a deal is still possible this year but
the chances
are waning last night boris johnson left
brussels in a blaze
he'd come here for a meal and a deal he
got the food
but the agreement remains elusive we
are willing to grant access to the
single market to our
british friends it's the largest single
market in the world
but the conditions have to be fair they
have to be fair for our
workers and for our companies and this
fine
balance of fairness has not been
achieved so far
our negotiators and are still working
and we will take a decision on sunday
thank you
no deal now looks much the most likely
option
adam parsons sky news brussels